let's jump over over to some uh domestic
issues very important domestic cultural
issues that will shock the soul we have
the story from yahoo life ben shapiro
and jeremy boring of the daily wire
announced jeremy's razors campaign
against harry's if you guys haven't seen
this yet you've got to watch the best
the greatest commercial ever they
released in the daily wire and it's
legit really really good basically the
daily wire was sponsored by harry's
razors harry's razors got tweeted at by
a high school kid no joke like a person
who said i'm in high school
and with two followers and said you guys
are bigots so harry's was like we hereby
denounce the daily wire
so the daily wire has launched i hate
harrys.com and they've launched their
own jeremy's razors with this commercial
and it's brilliant not only is it funny
it's silly it's over the top he takes a
flamethrower to harry's and gillette
he goes after these companies who hate
you not not just terry's but also
gillette saying you know men are too
toxic or whatever and now the daily
wires launch their own male male
grooming products i think it's brilliant
for two reasons one the cultural issue
of it taking back the culture bringing
bringing back comedy
i'm looking at what the daily wire is
doing i'm seeing the way they're filming
things and i'm like this feels very much
like 20 20 2009 2010 vice
you know when it was when it was edgy
funny
over the top offensive when it was vice
when it was vice well and so the
interesting thing and i reported a year
ago that this was in the works and i
kind of figured maybe it wasn't going to
happen and i'm glad that it did happen
because it seems like a silly thing and
i remember when i reported it i was like
is this newsworthy but it absolutely is
when you think about it because what the
daily wire is doing is
creating this parallel infrastructure
to the so-called mainstream
infrastructure and there if you look at
like gina carano she gets purged from
hollywood she's a legit actress she gets
purged and the daily wire creates a soft
landing pad for her which then creates
more incentives for other people in
hollywood to be open about what they
think because they can land somewhere
when they get purged and somewhere
legitimate and so when you create this
parallel infrastructure you create real
competition to the the monopoly that
locaism has on corporate america and so
that i mean we talk about monopolies in
antitrust but this is like a an
ideological monopoly and there's no way
to create competition for it because
every single corporation is dominated by
this ideology and that's what they're
doing well it's it's similar to the
cancellation arbitrage that we were
literally just talking about with sort
of the new world order versus the
alternative world order because
sanctions on the international stage on
the domestic stage is cancellation and
so russia china india building up their
own parallel economy it actually kind of
mirrors what we're seeing happening
domestically with conservatives or just
sort of anti-woke companies and
economies of scale starting to be built
out and now supply chains
parallel social media everything from
rumble to um you know various social
media platforms that are being built out
and it's it's very similar how the
mainstream is the one that's kicking
people out but because you've kicked out
now so many people well that's enough to
form a critical mass where you can now
build your own structure in your system
so we're seeing it happening
domestically with things like this but
we're also seeing it happening
internationally
i think's falling apart are things
breaking apart you know the liberal
world order this unified system visa
mastercard is being split here in the
united states the economy is being split
it might be a way to bypass uh what's
what would you call it where there's
when one superpower raises up and then
there's maybe a way to binary
i don't know because when you look at
the way russia got economically
cancelled there's no way to strike back
when you're a military and then you get
canceled by visa there's no country to
attack with your military it's all money
what could happen is starvation and then
people rise up against the starvation
like hey you can't starve us like this
then they take up arms and are called
villainized and then then that could
cause some sort of
conflict but i don't think it's going to
get that extreme
because uh russia china and the united
states are capable of growing their own
food for the most part well like that
but russia and china can direct i mean
they have a massive border with each
other they can directly trade they don't
or you know they have some in you know
talk about central asia they have
mutually beneficial countries that are
that they have good relations with that
they can trade through so they don't
need to you know the united states navy
can't interdict trade between china and
russia so you know they don't need us
basically what we need in the united
states is more of what the daily wire is
doing oh yeah shaving products
so whenever you you know not only that
but daily wire has a streaming service
they're building up right i'm totally
jealous of the stuff these guys are
working on because
they're they're hitting the nail on that
with the hammer so we need to think
about woke companies that have
either a monopoly or you know close to
one and then start actually making
products yeah so and one of the most
interesting things i've experienced in
reporting on the daily wires kind of
ascent is
being on the set of tara on the prairie
which is the new gina karana movie
was fascinating because i was talking to
all of these people just from the crew
who have spent their careers in
hollywood and they're not sort of like
some of them are like red meat
conservatives but a lot of them aren't
they're just artists and finally i think
when you create again those landing pads
it's not just that top build uh talent
it's not just your gina karanos it was
makeup artists um it was people on the
crew and to a degree that i was really
surprised by who weren't just like oh
hey it's another job they were like no
no we're here because we're really
excited not to promote a conservative
message but to promote the message that
we're giving a middle finger to
hollywood and that's what artists need
to feel comfortable doing and the daily
wire is creating spaces for that and
it's it's going to be really really
powerful at least so far it seems like
it has been and the talent that they're
snatching up is also very interesting
yeah yeah the fascinating thing is and
i'm watching the commercial and it's
remarkably well made in terms of
production quality
yeah it's just absolutely freaking over
we you want to roll that thing we have
to we have to remember
it's like was it like three or four
minutes okay but he has a he has a
flamethrower that's awesome you know
i've done um candace's show down there a
couple of times and just to talk about
you know the behind the scenes of that
they have a live studio audience yeah
where they do the show and the show is
shot live to tape and so you've got
people that are in there a couple
hundred people per episode that and
everybody's you know dressed very
professionally dressed like really
really nice
um the audience is you know kept live
there's like an mc that kind of comes in
between when they're changing up the
sets i mean there's so much that goes on
behind the scenes there it's wild yeah
and their gift shop is one of the things
that sounds silly but that blew me away
because if you if you go to their gift
shop and they have one um outside the
set where they do candace's show
it's things that it's sort of like
inside daily wired jokes but you can see
how they're tapping into this really
kind of i don't know cultural populist
sentiment that i don't think anybody
else has come close to doing yet i have
always loved the jokes they've had on
this show it's always been a running
joke that ben is gonna fire michael
knowles it's always in a running joke
that matt is a cranky old crab he's an
old coo he's not even that old but he's
just that's his persona they come up
with these personas they're very
personable they're very funny they get
along with each other they smoke cigars
together i think it's awesome so harry's
this is this is interesting i'm you know
i don't know of any companies that have
co-ceos that like a normal thing because
the daily wireless joint venture co-ceo
yeah but the uh we have a statement here
from jeff raider they say co-founder and
co-ceo of harry's he states we created
harry's to offer better shaving and
grooming products for everyone we
believe deeply in free speech but draw
the line at hate we'll continue to
support our customers and community with
kindness and compassion a spokesperson
from the brand continued by saying that
harry's does advertise across the
various media including the conservative
fox news however the brand is not
associated with entities that engage in
or endorse hate speech
um ladies and gentlemen
if you have a hairy subscription you
should cancel it and get a jeremy
subscription yeah
because you know here's here's the
challenge with netflix and disney if you
want to watch the latest disney movie
it's disney or nothing baby if you want
to watch those netflix series it's
netflix or nothing if you want to shave
your face it's harry's or jeremy's yeah
and jeremy is the company who are like
we don't hate you we just want your
money and harry's at the company and
says we actually do hate some of you
yeah we hate you because you hate so
we're gonna hate you and
there's there's another really
interesting and i think uh dark element
to this which is and the example i
always use is like why on earth is
stephen colbert um one of the most and
often on the ratings the most popular
host in late night and we can talk about
greg gudfeld which i think is another
amazing story but stephen colbert he is
objectively the worst comedian in late
night and he's also the most partisan
comedian in late night which just
completely flips the script you used to
have johnny carson's writer sit down
every night and ask themselves the
question what is going to make america
laugh tonight stephen colbert's writers
sit down every night and think what is
what is going to make resistance boomers
laugh tonight and he wins because he has
cornered that niche audience and he has
built this loyal following among that
niche because no longer do you need 15
million viewers to be the king of late
night you need a reliable three to four
million viewers to be the king of late
night and this happens with the death of
mass media and the death of popular
culture in different sections of the
economy and that's why harry's razors is
going to feel more comfortable they want
to be the razors for progressives it's
like the dumb gillette commercial but
but look
i think what colbert realized in a lot
of a lot of these hosts is that you're
not going to get a general market
anymore exactly so they've abandoned the
idea yes and that's that's
hyperpolarization it's very scary to me
i was just watching it it's smart on a
business level but not on a cultural
level it's terrifying i was watching
starting tomorrow everybody on the show
has to wear maga hats with trump 20 24
hours because we've realized you know
i was thinking this dialogue last night
watching johnny johnny carson and what i
was watching was the drew carey his
first appearance on carson 91 and johnny
is so was such a loving host
like his favorite thing to do is show
new talent to the world right but it was
all centralized at that time in the in
the early 90s 80s before the internet
there weren't a million comedians now
there's like a million there's like a
hundred thousand or ten ten thousand so
you can't there's no like
funnel to hose them through it's a
completely different environment the
fact that that show still exists is
insane yeah it's it's the wrong format
a wild man it doesn't make and he wasn't
apolitical by the way he told political
jokes but they were jokes that everybody
could laugh at so let me i wanna go
just my take on this is that a lot of
people pointed out that we do have this
sort of um
breakup of central pop culture and
certainly breakup of media but it there
have been times in america's history
where we've had uh huge flourishings of
alternate viewpoints if you go back to
the founding and you look at the
printing press if you look in the 1900s
at the level of the amount of newspapers
each city used to have
this idea that all media has to be
centralized and that everybody has to
can only watch you know three six and
ten and there's only a couple networks
that was just one moment in american
history and it's certainly not
talk radio has been around yeah we
really do yeah talk radio has been was
around prior to world war ii right but
then you need you need institutions like
the new york times to stop pretending
they represent or they're reporting on
the entire country thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you